do you think there's alien civilizations
out there
so there's a lot of folks who have kind
of written and talked about this is you
know the Drake equation which is like
you know the multiplying all the
probabilities together there's perhaps
more sophisticated takes like the uh the
Dark Forest you know which says that if
the universe is like a dark Forest where
the dumb ones that aren't hiding our
presence
um there's one calculation I saw and I
haven't reproduced myself but basically
says that the uh the assumption that
other civilizations have seen ours is
wrong because when you have like a
spherical radius for like the you know
electronic magnetic radiation that's
leaving our planet as that sphere gets
larger and larger it gets like smaller
and smaller amounts of energy so you
know you get farther out you're not
getting enough
um you know uh you know photons or or
would have you to to actually uh detect
it
um you know I don't know I actually
haven't looked into the math behind it
but I remember remember seeing that
argument so actually it is possible that
it's so diffuse when you go past a
certain you know number of light years
out that people you know that that alien
civilization wouldn't be able to detect
it right that's that's it's another
argument that's more basically about
signals from them from us yeah to be
able to signals colliding enough to uh
find the signal from the noise right
exactly intelligent signal yeah Hanson
has a article called grabby aliens
um have you seen his thing yes right and
so there's been on this podcast oh great
he's brilliant I like him he he pushes
you know boundaries in interesting ways
in every ways in all of the ways in all
the ways that's right I I like morale
he's you know he he's NASA team Andy
gravity aliens so he has he has this
interesting idea that uh the
civilizations
uh quickly learn how to travel close to
the speed of light right so we're not
going to see them until they're here
yeah that's possible I mean one of the
things is so here's for example a
mystery that we haven't yet Done Right
which or we haven't really figured out
yet which is
um
abiogenesis in the lab
right we've done lots of things where
you've got you can show macromolecules
binding to each other you can show you
know evidence for the so-called RNA
world abiogenesis is to go from you know
like non-life to life right in the lab
you can show microevolution obviously
with bacteria you can do artificial
selection on them lots of other aspects
of
um you know fundamental you know
biochemistry origins of Life stuff have
been established there's a lot of
plausibility arguments about the
Primitive environment and nitrogens and
carbons snapping together to get you
know the and you know the RNA world is
the the initial hypothesis but to my
knowledge at least we haven't actually
seen abiogenesis demonstrated now one
argument is you need just like this
massive world with uh you know so many
different reps before that actually
happens and
um one possibility is if we could do
atomic level you know simulations of
molecules bouncing each other it's
possible that in some simulation we
could find a path a represent will path
to abiogenesis and then just you know
replicate that in the lab right
um I I don't know okay uh but that seems
to me to be like a mystery that we still
don't fully understand like an example
of the prime number maze right one of
the most fascinating Mysteries one of
the most important yeah yeah and again
there may be some biochemists who's like
oh Balaji you didn't know about X Y and
Z that happened in the ABY agencies
field I I freely confess I'm not like at
you know oh current on it the last thing
I remember looking at it is Quran to
mean like up to the moment oh nice
that's a nice word that's a current I'm
probably mispronouncing it but yeah um
we'll edit it in post so sure correctly
with AI yeah yeah it will copy your
voice and it will pronounce it perfectly
correctly yeah in post one thing that I
do think was interesting is uh Craig
Venter a while back tried to make a
minimum viable sell
um where he just tried to delete all of
the genes that were that were not
considered essential and so it's like a
new life form and this was like almost
20 years ago and so on and that thing
was it was was viable in the lab right
and so it's possible that you could you
kind of reverse engineer so you're
coming at the problem from different
directions like RNA molecules can do
quite a lot you've got some you know
reasonable assumptions as to how that
could come together uh you've got like
sort of stripped down minimum viable
life forms and so there's it's not there
isn't stuff here you can see
microevolution you can see at the
sequence level you know if you do
molecular phylogenics you can actually
track back the bases there's actually so
it's not like there's no evidence here
there's a lot of tools to work with but
this in my view is a fascinating area
and actually also relevant to AI because
another form of abiogenesis would be if
we are able to give rise to a different
branch of life form the Silicon based as
opposed to carbon based you know to
stretch a point
um you give rise to something that
actually does meet the definition of
life for some definition of Life what do
you think that definition is for an
artificial life form because you
mentioned Consciousness yeah when will
it give us pause that we created
something foreign
by some definition or by some
spiritual poetic romantic philosophical
mathematical definition that it is alive
right and we wouldn't want to kill it so
a couple of remarks on that one is
um Francis Crick of of Watson and Crick
uh before he died I think his last paper
was published on something called the
claustrum okay and the thing is that you
know sometimes in biology or in any you
know domain people are sort of
discouraged from going after the big the
big questions right but he proposed the
claustrum is actually the organ that is
the seat of Consciousness it's like this
sheath that like covers the brain and uh
for mice if you and again I may be
recollecting this wrong so but you can
look at it my recollection is
um in mice if you disrupt this the mouse
is like very disoriented right it's like
it's the kind of thing which you know
Watson Creek were all about structure
implies function right they found the
structure of DNA this amazing thing and
you know they were marked in this very
under understated way at the end of the
paper that well obviously the this uh
gives a basis for how the genetic
material might be replicated and error
corrected because you know Helix unwinds
and you caught Pacer right so he was a
big structure function person and that
applies not just at the protein level
not just at the level of DNA but
potentially also at the level of organs
like the colostrum is kind of this
system integrated level right it's like
the the last layer in the neural network
or something you know
um and uh and so that's that's the kind
of thing that I think is worth studying
um
so Consciousness is another kind of big
abiogenesis a big question the prime
number is consciousness is a big
question
um and uh you know then definition of
life right uh there's folks gosh there's
I think so this one is something I'd
have to Google around but there was a
guy I think at Santa Fe Institute or
something who had some definition of
life and like some thermodynamic
definition
um but you're right that it's going to
be a multi-feature definition we might
have a Turing test like definition
frankly which is just if enough humans
agree it's alive it's alive right and
that might frankly be the operational
definition because you know viruses are
like this boundary case you know are
they are they alive or not most people
don't think they're alive but they're
they're they're they're on they're kind
of they're more alive than a rock